all six stones are considered snapped my
fingers they would all cease to exist
Tony there was no other way everybody
it's Charlie we got a whole bunch of new
Captain Marvel and Avengers for to talk
about interestingly enough we're getting
more of Captain Marvel in Avengers 4
than we got of her in her own movie so
far which is crazy but at least Kevin
Feige told us when we're getting that
Captain Marvel trailer so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're getting ready for Comic Con and
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you need to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so either
someone inside the bowels of Marvel
doesn't care about their job or
someone's disgruntled or something's
going on or they planned this leak but
an expanded version of the Avengers 4
promo
leaked out that we saw a couple of weeks
ago so there was this big Avengers 4
picture people were wondering where it
came from
is this legit now we have even more from
what seems like the same artist that was
leaking that other stuff so this is just
more detailed looks at what brie Larson
is gonna look like as Captain Marvel
along with Professor Hulk with the
version of his armor from the comics
Hawkeye in his ronin armor obviously
he's Ronin but they're probably just
gonna call him Clint most of the time so
we don't see him with the face mask on
I'm guessing if he has that mask he
wears it very briefly because for the
most part they want you to be able to
see those actors faces so if we see him
doing some really badass stuff he'll
probably wear it then take it off and
just leave it off for the rest of the
film I've already done a couple Hawkeye
videos the Russos explained that he's
under house arrest for a portion of
infinity war then when Avengers 4 picks
up a little while later remember there's
a brief time jump he's running special
missions probably for Nick Fury because
Nick Fury named dropped him at the end
of infinity war before he turned to dust
so the big thing here we see her in a
jacket we haven't seen this before we
saw a version of this concept art as
soon as last year so it looks on par
with what we've seen before but she does
not have the sash I think the last time
I talked about this my guess was is that
she would have the sash during
captain marvel movie because it's her
movie is the first time she'll wear the
costume they'll probably be most
faithful to all the versions of Carol
Danvers that there's been the original
Miss Marvel version the evolution of the
costume and then by the time she gets to
Avengers 4 when she shows up she has a
more practical armored version of the
costume so just like very minor tweaks
but like even Black Panthers costume
didn't change too much from Black
Panther to the events of infinity war
but you have to imagine that there's a
bunch of different effects houses that
are working on these movies so if there
are small inconsistencies between movies
and what costumes look like even if it's
supposed to be the same version of the
costume usually that's just a function
of a different effects house working on
it and being under a big time crunch so
if you ever notice small continuity
errors like that it just you have to
imagine the time crunch that people are
under so it's meant to be the same
costume but you have to imagine that a
long long time has gone by since the end
of the Captain Marvel movie in the
beginning of what happens during
infinity war so because of all this
stuff I figured it'd be good to do an
updated list of the 10 most powerful
characters still left alive or that we
think are alive inside the Marvel
Cinematic Universe after the snap sure
this includes cosmic beings people like
the watchers but not different versions
of the characters from other universes
number 10 is Baron Mordo because he's
strong enough to challenge Doctor
Strange while he's sorcerer supreme and
as far as we know he was not turned to
dust unless the rousseau specifically
said oh yes X person was turned to dust
just assume they're still alive the
Russos were nice enough to explain what
happened to a couple of the characters
we didn't see pop up during infinity war
number 9 is Adam warlock because he is
such a powerful character in the comics
but we haven't seen what they're gonna
do with him in the MCU yet we just know
that he's cooking inside that cocoon
right now so assume that he's at least
as powerful as he is in the comics
without the soul gem number 8 is Ghost
Rider because he is powerful enough to
take the souls of the most powerful
Marvel characters but we haven't seen
him in the MCU so I also put him a
little bit lower on the list that he
might be in the comics number 7 is hella
because we just saw her disappear at the
end of thor ragnarok but even though
she's supposed to be more powerful than
Thor when she's connected to the source
of her power she's been separated from
that remember the center of Asgard was
her power was she's been separated she's
probably healing meaning right now as of
Avengers 4 she's not quite as powerful
as she used to be number 6 I'll call a
tie between Thor and Professor Hulk not
the version that we saw fight Thanos an
infinity war but the professor Hulk
version which is sort of the upgrade
where he's wearing the armor he probably
won't be quite as powerful as world
breaker Hulk is in the comics but he's
meant to be the ultimate Hulk of the MCU
in Avengers 4 so that's why I put him
even odds with Thor number 5 is Captain
Marvel just because brie Larson and
Kevin Feige have separately talked about
her relative power scaling compared to
the other MCU characters she's powerful
enough to move planets which we haven't
seen Thor do yet we haven't seen Hulk do
yet but when brie Larson says that she's
powerful enough to move planets that
actually sounds like something that
they're going to address during the
Captain Marvel movie like she'll
actually have something to do with
moving a physical planet number four is
Thanos without the Infinity Gauntlet if
he's wielding the gauntlet and he shoots
to the top of the list but even without
the gauntlet he's still more powerful
than the most powerful Avengers combined
look at them all working together some
of the most powerful smartest Avengers
they weren't able to take him so imagine
in Avengers 4 in this concept art is
they're all flying at him while he's off
of the frame here they're just powerful
enough to defeat him that's how crazy
strong and resilient he is remember he's
an eternal so I'm guessing that when we
see more Eternals pop up in the MCU
they'll also explain the relative power
scaling but then number 3 I put the
watchers in the Celestials that might
still be alive that we just haven't met
yet there are more Celestials that are
alive we might meet some during Captain
Marvel or during guardians 3 then
obviously number two is Dormammu one of
the most powerful cosmic beings out
there but he's mostly rule over another
dimension so he's not an imminent threat
but he is weak against the Infinity
Gauntlet so if you have the gauntlet you
can hold him at bay and number one is
the Living Tribunal in eternity two
concepts that we know to exist but that
we haven't seen yet like the staff of
the Living Tribunal during Doctor
Strange
you can't have a staff of the Living
Tribunal if there is no Living Tribunal
Peter quill referenced eternity when ego
gave him the vision of the entire
universe at the same time so it just
broaden his mind so eternity is a big
grand concept you have to imagine that
it's the most powerful thing that we've
seen so far but relative to the
struggles of the Avengers you have to
imagine that it looks at them like fish
eating each other in a pond the pond
doesn't care about the inter politicking
of the fish it only cares that the pond
itself continues to exist so the only
time I think that eternity would
actually step in is if something really
powerful threatened its existence like
cosmic entities or the beyonders from
the comics but who knows if we'll ever
get into that concept in a future movie
let me know in the comments though what
do you think of the new Captain Marvel
art and which new cosmic entity or
celestial do you want to pop up in a
future Marvel film next Ant Man and the
wasp is dropping next week so I'll do
more Easter eggs and post-credits scenes
and stuff after it drops and people have
a chance to see it so no worries leave
all your requests in the comments below
but congratulations to steel bear you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details new round when I post
new Marvel click here for my
non-spoilery ant-man in the wasp review
and click here for the trailer for
Titans Young Justice in that new DC
streaming service thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]